[Musik]
jahr für jahr beginnen mehr als 100.000
menschen ein neues leben in der 2
was bringt sie dazu ihre heimat zu
verlassen und in der schweiz neu zu
beginnen und werden sie in der schweiz
ihr glück finden
[Musik]
wir haben menschen aus vier ländern bei
ihrem neuanfang in der schweiz begleitet
[Musik]
es wird hart für ihn bin ich kommen soll
ist schon voll
das geschah in der letzten folge
raul hat sich in indien von seiner
familie verabschiedet für ihr neues
leben in der schweiz lassen die inder
ein leben voller annehmlichkeiten zurück
ich bin aufgeregt und habe ein wenig
angst
so wird die ersten wochen alleine in der
schweiz verbringen um die ankunft von
mega und der gemeinsamen tochter die ja
vorzubereiten
[Musik]
ein abenteuer
wir werden sehen wie es ausgeht die
19-jährige älteste tochter der syrischen
familie als chef sitzt in libyen fest
die familie setzt ihre hoffnung jetzt
auf einen schweizer anwalt
ich habe seit drei jahren nicht mehr
gesehen
also ich habe hier einen brief von den
behörden mit neuer hoffnung brechen
rahman und radlern auf in die ersten
ferien ihres lebens habt ihr euch von
euren familien verabschiedet in
graubünden feiert lisa den sieg
portugals ein em finale
ihre arbeit als pflegehelferin erfüllt
sie mit freude
dennoch stellte sich fragen nicht um
gemenge ältere leute die eigentlich mich
auch brauchen würde sich alleine in den
ferien zieht es sie in die alte heimat
doch in die freude über das wiedersehen
mischen sich probleme in der familie
[Musik]
die franzosen fabian jury haben ihre
ersten schweizer anekdoten auf lager
neulich habe ich im zug soldaten gesehen
mit sturmgewehr und bier ihre hochzeit
feiern sie im kreise ihrer freunde nicht
in der schweiz sondern in ihrer alten
heimat
[Musik]
der große tag von jury und fabian anlass
für fabians freunde seine gefühle für
die neue heimat auf herz und nieren zu
prüfen
wieso genau findest du jetzt eigentlich
die schweiz plötzlich so toll
also ich hab meinen ersten lohn erhalten
im schweizer franken
genau da arbeiten sicher eine menge
grenzgänger oder das sind alles
franzosen kaum schweizer ehrlich gesagt
der einzige schweizer den ich bisher
kennengelernt habe ist sie ließ onkel
das ist der einzige erst schweizern
einer der freunde ist hält grenzgänger
auf einmal in frankreich grüßt wird man
tat beschützt
wenn ich zur arbeit gehe es sich oft
kleine kinder
die grössen immer wenn sie an einem
vorbeigehen beeindruckend sowas sollte
eigentlich normal sein
ich finde das super gut das ist
natürlich auch so eine sache die die
schweizer und franzosen sehen
das ist nicht immer einfach ich weiß
nicht ob wir uns jemals wirklich zu
hause fühlen können
deshalb interessiert es mich wie das bei
dir so läuft bist du zufrieden
absolut wir sind glücklich in der
schweiz kommt lasst uns essen
[Musik]
mit
für raul ist der große moment gekommen
willkommen in der schweiz ich mir
gefällt autos katar ja viel gepäck kein
problem
zum ersten mal in der schweiz zum ersten
mal ohne rückflugticket fahrgästen sind
wirklich hierher willkommen
einige jahre lang war wohl mehrmals pro
jahr beruflich in der schweiz
doch dieses mal ist anders bei der
landung wurde mir bewusst
das ist jetzt erst mal mein neues
zuhause
das ist schon ein besonderes gefühl wie
die sonne scheint ja sie beginnen hier
also wirklich ein neues leben genau das
ist wirklich anders was wo ich herkomme
gehört nun zu den mehr als 13.000 ändern
die in der schweiz leben er hat einen
hype feier job als ceo einer schweizer
firma fürs erste hat ihm seine firma ein
bewährtes appartements zürich
organisiert für die kommenden wochen
wird es sein neues zuhause sein
ich bin ein wenig in eile und ich muss
gleich weiter zu arbeiten und dann muss
ich los
ich werde sie und das fernsehteam heute
nicht mitnehmen kann
aber vielleicht an einem anderen tag
mit 36 ist raúl der neue ceo einer
schweizer firma die sich auf
solarenergie spezialisiert hat für den
manager ein großer karrieresprung etwas
ist seltsam hier ist es immer laut egal
wo oder auch einfach zu hause
es ist immer was los ich mach mal den
fernseher an
das ist mir einfach zu stehen hier
[Musik]
ja sicher ist sicher
ticket gültig
[Musik]
trauern und rasern verbringen die ersten
ferien ihres lebens in einem ferienlager
zum ersten mal mehrere tage ohne eltern
heute steht eine wanderung auf dem
programm
bevor die gruppe das ziel den ritt um
sie erreicht wartet eine fahrt mit einer
der steilsten standseilbahn der welt auf
sie jetzt habe ich aber schon angst
kannst du auch angst mit der fahre ich
sicher nicht zurück die menge der
herausforderung zum ersten mal in ihrem
leben müssen die beiden wandern und zwar
richtig
wir wandern da hoch zum stausee und was
es mit pause machen wir beim stausee und
dann geht es weiter zum nächsten sieg
okay für euch nein überhaupt nicht
irgendwie machen meine füße nicht mit
ich mache lieber vorkommen umso
schneller habe ich es hinter mir
jessica du bist die letzte das erste
ziel ist erreicht
der größte teil der gruppe besteht aus
einwanderern bergwanderungen kennen die
wenigsten dir den weg dort dahin geht's
jetzt gibt es sogar schnee es geht
weiter zum nächsten see
mit jeder zappen tine fällt die gruppe
weiter auseinander
rasern hält sich tapfer an der spitze
ihre schwester war waren jedoch tut sich
schwer
unmöglich ich bin das gewohnt ist alles
eine frage der übung dann kannst du mich
ertragen aber wunderschön
eigentlich wäre oben auf den bergen die
vergangenheit weit weg wenn sie nicht
ständig jemand zurückholen würde wie
weit beide in syrien geboren oder ist
das leben so eigentlich gut wie das ist
nun anders
im prinzip ähnlich wie hier aber dann
kam der krieg und jetzt haben die
menschen nicht mal genug zu essen
wir haben versucht uns zu schützen wo
wir gerade warm
wir waren ja nicht immer zu hause
manchmal wurden wir auch mitten in der
nacht bombardiert
[Musik]
du bist wirklich tapfer unter sonne
scheint du kannst du gar noch lachen
wenn du von schlimmen dingen erzählt was
soll ich denn machen
die hoffnung für einen am leben
[Musik]
elisabeth in ihrer alten heimat
unterwegs
das städtchen braga im norden portugals
war jahrzehntelang hier zu hause
die hat sie gelebt und geliebt ihre
beiden söhne großgezogen
bis sie vor zwei jahren in die schweiz
ging
[Musik]
wer sind eigentlich immer in zehn
minuten
wenn ich dort wo ich raus bereits am
ersten ferientag muss sich leader
allerdings um anstehende probleme
kümmern
[Musik]
ich komme auf mehrere monate lang hat
sich lisa auf diesen moment gefreut
meine liebe liebe mutter wie schön sie
zu sehen
ich komme um vor hitze und es dachte du
magst
sie sind in portugal ist es üblich dass
kinder ihre eltern liebsten mit ihren
augen
heute ist übrigens am tag samstag war
gestern
ich bin nicht aus dem haus gegangen die
brille ist schmutzig leaders mutter ist
noch kann sie alleine leben doch das
alter beginnt seine spuren zu
hinterlassen
um das wiedersehen zu feiern möchte
lieder ihrer mutter in ein restaurant
einladen
doch ihre mutter scheint verwirrt zu
sein etwas leichtes über wir fahren an
den start
das hier muss ich vorher noch nie wann
genau müssen sie das nehmen
zum frühstück aber jetzt ist doch abend
das vielleicht für morgen
aber jetzt ist doch nicht frühstückszeit
finde ich aber durcheinander
ich würde sagen wir fahren jetzt erst
mal an den strand
meine mutter aller zeiten verliert das
feuer immer diese neuigkeiten sie mir
irgendwann auf mich zukommen
die entwicklung wie man es halt nicht
mehr so ist gleich
irgendwann wenn sie nicht mehr mit ihren
tag um nachzuweisen dass wieder hilfe
braucht jemanden jemanden braucht oder
dass sie ein heim hat tagsüber nun dass
sie nach hause kommen kann
ich weiß nicht dass die sachen wo man
wenn man weit weg ist
ich kann das jetzt nicht so einschätzen
[Musik]
ich schaffe es nicht mehr mir alleine
meine nägel zu schneiden
das macht jetzt auch danach bisher hat
sie immer nur die pediküre gemacht
das gemeinsame essen tut den beiden gut
auch wenn portugals krise thema des
gesprächs ist es gibt immer mehr leute
die sagen sie hätten kein geld
vielleicht gebe es aber auch nur einfach
ständig aus lisa und ihre mutter haben
vieles gemeinsam
schon die mutter hatte zusammen mit lisa
einige jahre im ausland gelebt
raul hat sich im neuen top eingearbeitet
heute nimmt er sich einen tag frei um
sich um eine schule für tochter die ja
zu kümmern
es soll eine internationale schule rein
was für ein stoff 1 gewinnt die blume
der privatschule werden weltweit
anerkannt der manager denkt weit voraus
dreieinhalb dann in dieser klasse haben
sie hier viele nationalitäten eine menge
in dieser klasse allein haben wir
amerika brasilien japan dänemark italien
und finnland
das ist sehr international hier in
indien sprechen wir überall englisch
unsere muttersprache ist hindi aber an
den schulen wird in englisch
unterrichtet es wäre toll wenn meine
tochter hier deutsch lernen würde und
natürlich englisch
raul entdeckt eine neue welt eine welt
für die er in indien keine zeit hatte
hier lernen sie mit holz umzugehen zu
bohren
[Musik]
das ist ein ziemlich unabhängiges lernen
und viel praxisorientierter in indien
soweit ich das beurteilen kann
ich muss zugeben ich kenne mich da nicht
so aus bisher nicht so viel zeit mit
meiner tochter verbraucht wie ich
eigentlich sollte in indien ist es mehr
das klassische lernen hier geht man mehr
raus und experimentiert gerne ich mache
nur noch schnell ein paar fotos für
meine frau
[Musik]
die letzten töne der hochzeit sind
verklungen jetzt steht für julie und
fabia ein stück alltag in der schweiz an
pavia stellt sich fragen über seine
berufliche zukunft
er hat sich frei genommen um zu
recherchieren die nasa ingenieur in der
automobilbranche tätig ich bin
projektleiter für die entwicklung einer
komponente für einen elektromotor für
für diesen job bin ich in die schweiz
gekommen
es ist eine gute stelle allerdings füllt
mich die arbeit ehrlich gesagt nicht
mehr wirklich aus deshalb halte ich die
augen offen und schauen was sich sonst
auf dem arbeitsmarkt tut 5 uhr das
feierabend-bier hat eine leidenschaft
es gibt eine menge guter bücher mit
tollen ideen für handwerker besonders
für kunstschlosser als kind habe ich
mich wahnsinnig für alles interessiert
was mit dem mittelalter zusammenhängt
ich habe mir schwerter aus holz
gebastelt
das war cool aber ich wollte etwas
echtes mit einem freund haben wir dann
später angefangen richtige schwerter zu
schmieden
die wurden mit der zeit immer besser und
ich habe mich an anderem versuche das
hier zum beispiel ist meine erste
selbstgemachte truhe hier eine art
piraten koffer für die cofra platz das
ist schon recht gut verarbeitet sowohl
das metall wie auch das holz so was
mache ich gerne dass hier habe ich auch
selbst gemacht
während seines ingenieurstudiums hatte
ich fabia auch mit metallbau gefasst
das metall hat einen echten industrie
look das gefällt mir
fabian hat erfahren dass ein
kunstschmied in der nähe sein gewerbe
verkaufen möchte sein entschluss steht
fest er will den schritt in die
selbständigkeit wagen in portugal
nämlich wieder zeit für ein gespräch mit
marko ihrem älteren sohn
sie möchte ein thema ansprechen dass sie
auf dem magen liegt bei dem ende deines
studiums vor mehr als einem jahr ist
marco arbeitslos wie ein viertel der
unter 25-jährigen in portugal
du solltest die suche möglichst breit
streuen auch wenn es nicht einfach
gebiet ist
ich würde auch was anderes nehmen wenn
der lohn halbwegs okay wäre
weißt du heutzutage eher selten ein
korrekter lumia 800 euro pro monat
sollten noch wirklich drin liegen
gott sei dank kann marco kostenlos in
die pata pata monaten finanziell ist er
zu einem großen teil von deiner mutter
abhängig
manchmal denke ich ich sagte sie du
machen aber dazu fehlt mir der mut
du kannst jederzeit zu mir in die
schweiz kommen in portugal beträgt das
monatliche durchschnittseinkommen knapp
1300 franken liga verdient in der
schweiz mehr als das dreifache
das leben von auswanderern besteht doch
nur aus arbeiten und nach hause gehen
keine freunde kein sozialleben
aber wenn ich einen job in meinem gebiet
finden würde
beispiele geologie biologie oder sowas
dann würde ich ernsthaft darüber
nachdenkt mal auszuwandern
immerhin lisa hat es geschafft in der
schweiz
wie schwer das zu sagen aber sie hatte
keine wahl sie musste rechnungen zahlen
hätte sie mit dem marketing gehalten
portugal niemals geschafft und in ihrem
alter noch einen guten job zu finden ist
doppelt schwer
dann hat sie also genau das richtige
gemacht auch wenn es manchmal weh tut er
ja ich denke schon
knapp
herr
schade
[Musik]
meyer
schavan und reisen sind derzeit einer
woche in ihrem ferienlager
heute dürfen die angehörigen
vorbeischauen besonders der vater hat
sich schwergetan seine beiden töchter
alleine unterwegs zu wissen
eines haben die mädchen sehr vermisst
meine schwester hat unsere mutter
angerufen und ihr gesagt hast du zum
essen mitbringen
da hab ich vom minister nicht wolltest
den anderen zeigen mutter bier liefert
wie gewünscht
und jetzt wird sie neugierig hier schlag
dir also ich lasse hier regieren hier
und rasanter eine ganze woche ohne
aufsicht der eltern für die syrischen
mädchen ein großes abenteuer
[Musik]
diese woche haben wir wirklich tolle
sachen gemacht auch abends sogar bis
mitternacht
da haben wir viel spannendes gemacht die
eltern können sich nur auf arabisch
verständigen
die kinder sind ihnen einen großen
schritt voraus ihr rat vor allem
italienisch gesprochen
mehr lathen hier sollten wir mit ich
kein arabisch sprechen
machen wir aber trotzdem möchten wir mal
probieren möchten sie lieber das hier
oder mit tomaten mit tomaten natürlich
jetzt vertrauen vater für die mädchen
ein großer schritt nach vorne angekommen
sind hatte ich zuerst sehr starkes
heimweh aber inzwischen gefällt es mir
wahnsinnig gut hier zu liebsten würde
ich gar nicht mehr zurück nach hause
ihr könnt ihr einfach hier bleiben
machst einfach bei der nächsten gruppe
mit
roll hat sich an sein neues leben als
hausmann gewöhnt der einkauf im
schweizer supermarkt ist für ihn zur
routine geworden
die indischen straßen stände vermisst er
nicht
der persönliche kontakt ist mir
eigentlich nicht so wichtig viel
wichtiger es mir dass es hier eine große
auswahl
so kann ich alles auf einmal erledigen
was für eine auswahl
eigentlich hat er als mutter ihn ermahnt
frische lebensmittel zu kaufen
das wort frisch hergestellt
schauen wir mal wie gut mein deutsches
hier zum beispiel wenn ich nicht weiter
weiß
da habe ich eine app die kann das
scannen und direkt übersetzen weiße
bohnen in tomatensoße fertig habe ich
eben gelernt aber schon wieder vergessen
raul interessiert sich für seine neue
heimat
auch im supermarkt rivella ich habe
gehört das ist typisch schweizerisch das
werde ich mal probieren
meine zeit
ich brauche eine pause
hätte ich doch nur an einkaufswagen
genommen weil alpen draufsteht
weil da stehen chili und alten zusammen
drauf lustiger mix erinnert mich an wo
ich herkomme und wo ich jetzt lebe
noch vor wenigen wochen hätten in indien
vs angestellte solche einkäufe für ihn
erledigt
und natürlich nach hause getragen
[Musik]
leader genießt in portugal die
gemeinsamen momente mit ihren söhnen
sowie es war bevor sie sich entschloss
alleine in die schweiz zu gehen
der jüngere sohn edoardo lebt bei seinem
vater als sieger ging war er 20
ein atem westen dreht sich das gespräch
erneut um die arbeit zeigt man seine
hand ausgestreckt lassen
webcast mehr eduardo studiert informatik
er nutzt den sommer um sich etwas dazu
zu verdienen
die gelegenheitsjobs hin oft anstrengend
und schlecht bezahlt so auch diesmal
was hast du gearbeitet ich habe den
boden in einer fabrik gereinigt mit
einem großen staubsauger nein mit
spachtel mit schutzmaske
[Applaus]
du hast nicht mal einen schutz gegen
staub
das war gar nicht so staubig da hätten
sie aber wenigstens den boden mit wasser
abspritzen können ist nun mal so
nicht einmal 30 franken für einen ganzen
tag harter arbeit alltag in portugal
die schlechte wirtschaftliche lage hat
denn auch lisa zu dem entschluss
gebracht auszuwandern
das ist sicher nicht so einfach sie so
alleine und dazu noch in einem kleinen
dorf das hat sie uns zumindest so
erzählt ich habe schon das gefühl dass
in der schweiz auch nicht alles einfach
ist die leute denken immer dass man sich
dort eine goldene nase verdient aber ich
weiß dass das ganze auch dort nicht so
einfach ist wie man vielleicht denkt
[Musik]
im tessin ist der anwalt der von pwc
unter weg zur familie als ihre älteste
tochter sitzt in libyen fest
zusammen mit ihrem mann und ihren beiden
kindern seit mehreren wochen bemüht sich
der anwalt um eine
familienzusammenführung in der schweiz
guten namen wie geht es dir gut und dir
ebenfalls dabei ist eine angehende
sozialarbeiterin eine freundin der
familie
welcher sender ist das habt ihr
parabolantenne die familie hofft auf
gute nachrichten
leider hat der anwalt schlechte
neuigkeiten
wer über selbst ich erkläre mal ich habe
mich beim eda in bern erkundigt leider
ist es nicht mehr möglich oder gesucht
direkt bei einer botschaft im ausland
einzureichen erneut müssen die kinder
für ihre eltern übersetzen
besonders für die mutter ist die
nachricht nur schwer zu verdauen
wie ist denn derzeit die situation der
schwester
wir sprechen nur übers internet mit ihr
wesen der stadt misrata oder haben sie
etwas erzählt
sie sagt dass es ihnen nicht besonders
gut geht
auch den kindern nicht und sie fragt uns
immer was sagt denn der anwalt eine
große enttäuschung für die ganze familie
münchen nach europa bleibt der schwester
nur noch der gefährlichen weg über das
mittelmeer von libyen aus scheint mir
das besonders mit den kindern keine gute
idee von tunesien aus wäre es sicher
besser aber sie müssten dann in jedem
fall in italien asyl beantragen
nein nicht dass mir nicht dass mir die
situation ist überall schwieriger
geworden
[Musik]
der krieg in syrien hat die familie
getrennt was bleibt ist die hoffnung
dass ist die tochter doch noch in die
schweiz schafft
irgendwie
[Musik]
juli geht ihrem alltag nach jeden morgen
nimmt sie denselben zug zur arbeit
mit der zeit hat sie dort einige der
pendler etwas näher kennengelernt
alleskleber gier eineinhalb stunden hin
eineinhalb stunden zurück
ich war noch mit anderen inseln
unterwegs
ihr wart noch an mehreren orten einen
trinken
nein nur um den trip von rom sie dürfen
gerne mitkommen
alle sind herzlich willkommen ich melde
mich noch mal
der job ist wie die tägliche lange
anhalten wird
sie liebt ihre arbeit als
projektverantwortliche für misslich
das ist ganz was ja nicht ihre schuld
allerdings hat ihr die arbeit bisher
nicht bei der integration geholfen
verkehr kollege nur wenige meiner
kollegen sprechen französisch die
umgangssprache ist hier englisch
die leute hier kommen aus der ganzen
welt
ich würde sagen englisch ist hierbei
nicht so eine art muttersprache meine
arbeitskollegen blieben hier im laden
und wir werden aber ich gehe hier
eigentlich nie aus und von denen kaum
einer nach richard e ich lerne gerade in
ich mit meinem kollegen abgefangen dem
song frei die arbeit trägt sicher nicht
meine integration in der schweiz bei das
passiert wie mehr durch menschen die ich
außerhalb kennenlernen
bei wanderungen beim pendeln oder die
man sich lange zu kennen lernen
eine menge leute hier fahren an den
wochenenden zurück die sich nach
frankreich
so kommt es dass ich die meisten hier
wirklich nie außerhalb der arbeit
[Musik]
u
die luft ist wie champagner roll ist auf
der suche nach einer wohnung für sich
und seine familie
das nächste café ist 15 minuten entfernt
[Musik]
das ist ja fernab der menschheit seit
zwei monaten lebt jetzt in der schweiz
und die hat bereits ihre spuren in ihm
hinterlassen
ich würde sagen ich bin höflicher
geworden
es gibt so viele unterschiede zwischen
der schweiz
hier muss ich mich selbst ums essen
kümmern selber putzen uhr geöffneten
verkehrsmittel belassen
das ist alles ganz anders als ich es aus
indien gewohnt auf seinem radar ein
wohnort in der nähe der neuen schule
seiner tochter wollen wir uns die
wohnung anschauen weil er gerne
als kriterium nummer eins der handy
empfangen
kein empfang nicht mal im badezimmer
warum gibt es in der schweiz eigentlich
immer zwei waschbecken damit jeder sein
ding machen kann ohne dass man sich in
die quere kommt 1 für den mann ein für
die frau der manager ist organisiert
nach den obligatorischen fotos für seine
frau nebenkosten hause geld arbeitet er
eine vorbereitete checkliste ab wie weit
es ist zu fuß bis zum see circa eine
viertelstunde 15 minuten
hier ist alles so wahnsinnig teuer und
ich kenne die regeln nicht da bin ich
wesentlich vorsichtiger indien
[Musik]
sollen wir uns die nächste wohnung
anschauen
max aus die wäre dann direkt eine etage
tiefer gestimmt das hatte ich vergessen
wird
fabia ist einer der wenigen seiner
kollegen die nach feierabend nicht nach
frankreich zurück fahren
er hat sich für die schweiz als wohnsitz
entschieden
eine weitere entscheidung hat er vor
wenigen tagen getroffen
hier ist dem ruf seines herzens gefolgt
und hat eine kunstschmiede gekauft und
will sich selbständig machen
der moment ist gekommen die kollegen in
die großen pläne einzuweihen und hast du
unterschrieben
naja also dann kündige ich auch das gibt
eine richtig große abschiedsfeier
jetzt muss erst mal funktionieren auf
deinen und auf dich auf die neuen
abenteuer so lange davon geträumt und
mich nicht getraut das kann ja auch in
die hose gehen
der erste schritt ist getan
ich werde ganz schön ran müssen
das liebste doch aber ich habe ihm keine
frau zu hause wenn die dann schlecht
drauf ist wenn ich abends um zehn nach
hause komme ein neues leben
wir werden den gürtel wohl erst mal
enger schnallen müssen schien ihr gehalt
du musst halt so viel verdient wie ein
manager genau am besten noch mit
goldenen fallschirm auf jeden fall werde
ich nicht mehr den ganzen tag vor dem
computer sitzt erstmal weniger geld in
der kasse sein aber dafür wird mich die
arbeit glücklich machen
[Musik]
geschafft
und das passierte in der nächsten folge
frontgrill schweiz die einwanderer
mathematik ist nicht mein ding jeden
fall einen geschichte und geografie safe
lernt italienisch um sich besser zu
integrieren
die familie genießt ihr leben in der
schweiz aber die nachrichten aus syrien
machen ihr täglich sorgen
[Musik]
lisa ist zurück aus ihren ferien
sie hofft nun endlich auch eine neue
liebe zu finden
[Gelächter]
raul trifft die letzten vorbereitungen
für die ankunft einer familie
jetzt wissen die rechnung wo sie
hinmüssen für mega beginnt ein neuer
lebensabschnitt lampen fabia startet in
die selbstständigkeit eine
belastungsprobe für die beziehung von
postern geht klar aber pfingsten habe
ich cricket
[Musik]
mit